Heute im Rasenfunk?
Nein!
Der Blick auf andere Menschen.
Hallo und herzlich Willkommen in der Rasenfunk-Liga. Wie schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.social und bei Blue Sky. Aber um niemanden könnte es weniger gehen als um mich. Star sind in der Ligatur die Gäste. Und da ist unter anderem hier Fabian Pakulat. Hallo Fabian, schön, dass du da bist. Wir können dich unter anderem auf viva.la.liga.de lesen. Wird natürlich wie immer verlinkt. Die Informationsquelle zum spanischen Fußball. Und ich weiß gerade noch nicht genau, wie viel man von deinem Video sehen wird. Aber du sitzt heute in einem ganz besonders schönen Setting, Fabian.
Das ist aber nur die zweitgrößte Legende gewesen in dem MLS-Cup-Finale. Da linken nackt bei dir darf man, muss man natürlich in der Ligatour auch mal genannt haben, zum vierten Mal Meister geworden in den USA.
Genau, und ich finde es auch schön, dass wir dieses Finale damit angesprochen haben. Es gab nämlich einen Hörer, der hat vor sechs Wochen oder so schon gefragt, macht ihr dann nach dem Finale eine Folge und ich habe es mir dann auch notiert und so weiter, aber es kam der DFL-Investor dazwischen. Ich schaffe es leider nicht, tut mir leid, lieber Hörer. Aber schön, dass wir es auf diese Art und Weise nochmal angesprochen haben. Und Chiellini hat ja auch in der letzten Saison die Meisterschaft geholt. Also dass man jetzt wieder im Finale der Playoffs war, auch nicht so zufällig. Jetzt weiß ich gar nicht mehr, wo wir sind. Ne, wir sind schon durch. Wir sind beim Moment in La Liga. Das heißt, Fabian ist wieder dran.
Wir haben ein Momentum, das eigentlich nicht sehr schön ist, aber das ein paar schöne Anekdoten nebenbei hat. Das war eine ziemlich heftige Geschichte beim Spiel Granada gegen Bilbao. Da ist während der Partie ein Fan an einem Herdstillstand verstorben. Und das war irgendwie ziemlich kurios, denn der Torhüter von Bilbao, Unai Simon, hat ein bisschen mitbekommen, dass auf der Tribüne was los war, ist dann zu Schiri und hat dann gebeten, das Spiel zu unterbrechen. Er hat quasi diesen Spielabbruch so ein bisschen eingeleitet. Wurde deswegen auch von den Granada-Fans dann auch zu Recht, nicht gefeiert, aber ihm wurde dafür applaudiert. Es wurde dann versucht, den älteren Herrn, der schon lange Vereinsmitglied oder Dauerkartenbesitzer bei Granada ist, diesen wiederzubeleben. Das ist dann nicht gelungen. Dementsprechend haben sich beide Teams schnell darauf geeinigt, das Spiel abzubrechen. Das war in der 17. Minute schon. Bilbao hat dort schon mit 1-0 geführt oder 0-1 in dem Fall. Das Spiel war am Sonntag, es wurde dann am Montag wieder angepfiffen. Vor dem Spiel haben sich die beiden Kapitäne von Bilbao und Granada auf die Tribüne gegangen mit einem Trauerkranz und haben den dort niedergelegt auf den Platz des Fans, der dort verstorben war. Natürlich gab es eine Schweigeminute. Es wurde ganz schön inszeniert, die ganze Geschichte. Es war einfach eine ganz faire Geschichte zwischen beiden Teams, wie sie sich da verhalten haben und wie das alles abgelaufen ist. Das war mit Sicherheit der Moment des Spieltags in der Liga.
Da kann man wenig ergänzen. Das ist einfach so, das lassen wir einfach genauso stehen. Ein bisschen schwer danach, jetzt wahrscheinlich mit was Sportlichem zu kommen. Ich weiß nicht, Uli, was du in deiner Liste noch hast.
Mein Moment des Spieltags ist dann doch ein schöner, glaube ich. Mohamed Salah hat das 1-1 gemacht gegen Crystal Palace und damit seinen 200. Treffer für Liverpool im 326. Spiel. Und damit ist er das 1.5. in Liverpool durchaus weitreichender Geschichte, der das geschafft hat. Und vielleicht wird einem nochmal klar, wenn man sich vor Augen führt, wer alles nicht 200 Tore geschossen hat bei Liverpool. Da sind Namen drunter wie Steven Gerrard, wie Robbie Fowler, Kenny Doglish, wie John Aldridge, wie John Toschek, der nicht mehr in die Nähe kommt, Kevin Keegan, John Barnes. Also nicht nur das 200. Tor, auch das 150. Premier League Tor im Übrigen, auch da gibt es nicht so viele, die das gepackt haben, sondern das 1.1, das dann letztlich logischerweise wegbereiter war fürs 2.1 und damit auch die Tabellenführung für Liverpool. Ein schöner Moment, vor allen Dingen deshalb, weil man, glaube ich, manchmal so irgendwie gar nicht versteht, wie gut Mohamed Salah war und wie er oft einfach Dinge tut, die wir so für gegeben hinnehmen. Und 200 Tore, das ist schon echt sehr, sehr gut.
Aber absolut. Das braucht man jetzt nicht relativ.
Das würde ich unterschreiben, ja.
Aber hat er auch mal gegen Chilini getroffen? Das ist die einzige Frage, die jetzt noch zu klären ist. Wahrscheinlich hat er sogar das geschafft.
Gut möglich, ja.
Er hat dem Gorilla sein Essen weggenommen. Welchen Moment haben wir in der Serie A, Christian?
Ich habe auch noch ein sehr schönes Tor mitgebracht. Ich muss noch ganz kurz die Klammer, das hatte ich vorhin bei Pavoletti vergessen. Das Tor, jetzt 90 plus 9 zum 2-1, war ein Fallrückzieher. Nur so, das ist mir vorhin durchgerutscht. Mein Moment des Spieltags war, ich habe es vorhin angedeutet, es gab Atalanta gegen Milan. Es war ein sehr aufregendes Spiel, das Atalanta 3-2 gewonnen hat. Ja, tolles Spiel. Und das Tor fiel auch in der Nachspielzeit. Und zwar das 3-2 für Atalanta durch Luis Moriel, Kolumbianer, und zwar ein überragendes Tor mit der Hacke. Ich kann es nur jedem ans Herz legen. Wer Lust drauf hat, schaut es euch nochmal an, weil es ist ein grandioses Hackentor. Luis Moriel, Kolumbianer, mittlerweile auch schon über 30, mittlerweile nicht mehr Stammspieler bei Atalanta, weil er logisch auch mit Skamaka, mit Decetalare, mit Lukman, mit Thuré, der ja aus Spanien kam, der noch keine Sekunde gespielt hat, der kam für 30 Millionen und war bisher verletzt. Bei Atalanta ist auch die Tiefe im Angriff sehr, sehr gegeben. Moriel hat in der Europa League auch schon Tore geschossen, aber in der Liga hat er noch nicht getroffen, kam oft als Joker. Ich finde Moriel als Spieler großartig. Auf der Liste der fittesten Spieler würdest du ihn nicht ganz vorne finden. Das ist einer, der den Fußball im Blut hat. Der hat immer wieder solche Momente, hat großartige Tore mit dabei, weil er eine überragende Technik hat. Er ist beidfüßig, er kann mit links und rechts aus der Distanz abschließen, da kennst du keinen Unterschied. Er hat auch dieses Kreative, dieses Besondere, dieses kolumbianische Flair. Schaut es euch an, ein grandioses Tor mit der Hacke, das allein schon sehenswert wäre, aber dadurch, dass es auch noch die Entscheidung gegen Milan herbeigeführt hat und Atalanta jetzt dadurch auch wieder voll im Rennen und Platz 4 um die Champions League Plätze ist. Da ist es wirklich sehr eng. Da ist die Roma, da ist Fiorentina, da ist Atalanta, da ist Bologna. Also es war auch ein sehr, sehr wichtiges Tor, nicht nur ein sehr schönes Tor und dementsprechend der Moment des Spieltags.
Sehr, sehr gerne genommen. Und damit bleibt mir nur noch euch ganz herzlich zu danken. Danke, Fabian Pakulat.
Danke euch. Ich nutze die ganze Stunde und wünsche euch ein sehr schönes Weihnachtsfest. Genießt die Zeit. Lasst euch gut gehen. Uli, viel Spaß beim Boxing Day und wir sehen uns dann nächstes Jahr wieder.
Ach, sehr, sehr schön. Da kann man natürlich nur einstimmen. Uli, dir auch vielen herzlichen Dank und ebenfalls viel Spaß beim Boxing Day.
Vielen Dank. Ich wünsche euch da draußen auch alle viel Spaß beim Boxing Day, weil hoffentlich alle mit dabei sind. Sehr schön. Es gibt sogar einen Heiligabend-Fußball dieses Mal aus England. In diesem Sinne ein frohes, ruhiges Fest. Es war ein schönes Ligatour-Jahr.
Aber wirklich, das kann ich so zurückgeben. Danke dir, Uli. Und natürlich auch danke, Christian.
Ja, kann ich auch nur so mich anschließen. Vorher ist die Fanszeit sehr schön. Ich freue mich sehr, wenn es dann im neuen Jahr weitergeht.
Aber absolut. Und natürlich in Abwesenheit auch danke an alle anderen Gäste, die wir in diesem Jahr schon hatten. Die Ligatour ist ein ganz besonderes Format hier im Rasenfunk. Das, wie alles von euch finanziert wird, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und das könnt ihr jetzt auch via PayPal und Kreditkarte tun. rasenfunk.de slash-Supporters-Club. Da kann man dann auch mal so einen Einmalbetrag rüber schicken, weil Las Palmas mal angesprochen wurde in der Folge. Nur so als Beispiel. Das wäre doch ein guter Grund. Also danke für eure Unterstützung. Bleibt gesund, bleibt dem Rasenfunk gebogen. Und bis bald hier wieder. Macht's gut.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.